so um one final odds-related exercise i
wanted to do
shorter time control remember that
exercise i tortured you with
in our last session we're not gonna do
that full scale we're just gonna play
one game
we're gonna i'm gonna give you five
minutes and i'm gonna give up
queen and two rooks and i want to see if
you can beat me oh jesus okay but no
hands and we're just gonna do this once
i promise
[ __ ] yeah that one was embarrassing
five minutes and i'm gonna tell you they
give you the instructions about the
first couple of moves as i did
previously okay all right so let's do
five five
i did all right challenge
okay so go move your knight out to f6
take the queen bring your d pawn to d6
take the rook bishop e6
bishop e6 oh yes and take the rook and
now start and this time i
you know i can confirm stuff you ask but
um i basically want you to beat
all me i'm going to mute myself for now
and i just want you guys to know that
you know i do cuss with charlie and
stuff
and it's not because i'm trying to
change my personality or anything that's
just the
the chemistry that we've built i hope
people understand that that should not
be a surprise to anybody
um and i'm sorry if there are any kids
watching or stuff but
uh parents you should know that uh and
you know i'll
i try to keep it to a minimum but that
just does happen with charlie and stuff
i know you guys know
i i know you guys are doing but i just
did want to clarify that point
yeah i know you guys are kidding just i
but i did just want to clarify that
okay so i'm just going to develop my
pieces i want to see how charlie is able
to handle this material
will he do stuff like open the center
will he
will he be able to follow principles
will he be able to avoid blunders and
play quickly
and um i'm giving him five minutes here
which is a lot of time to win a position
like this but he is rusty so
i you know i would understand it if he
doesn't
he's fianchettoing his bishop
how much do my lessons cost so i'm not
taking any students on right now
um and i don't usually reveal stuff like
my thank you the fps
appreciate everybody's support and the
subs and really everything
it's awesome um i might have missed some
subs i've disabled the alerts during
this session
so we can more easily put it on youtube
and we have jan napanishi in the chat
wow what an honor
we have nepo in the chat uh really just
absolutely hop and party here i'm gonna
go d5 c5 was a really good move
charlie is showing signs that he knows
to open the center
let's just see if he can cleanly win
this game wow this is awesome
welcome welcome nephew i think he needs
to learn from this as well
i don't think he would be able to win
this in five minutes honestly okay takes
the bishop good job
jmpy gifting to nepo thank you
yes only you would need six minutes at
least
um yeah we're down two rooks and a queen
but charlie is overthinking where to put
the bishop
so bishop g4 here i'll commentate the
game bishop g4 would be the best move
um it just you know pressuring the
knight you could also drop the bishop
back and i want to make this point to
charlie he's always had trouble
retreating making retreating moves
retreating moves are part of chess there
isn't an inherent reason why they're bad
okay good my sore throat is beginning to
pass which is good
and um all i needed was a healthy dose
of charlie
so yes okay perfect now obviously i'm
gonna move my knight away
and i'm not going to let him trade any
pieces voluntarily now what would you do
guys if you were black
what would you do if you were black here
what would be a good thing to do here
yeah knight f4 would be a great move
activating the knight that's on the rim
i'm a little bit worried charlie's gonna
do okay he castle's good
so i'm going to chase his bishop away
bishop to d let's see how easily he
makes
yeah nice okay he's actually playing
very well for the most part he's doing
some stuff that's
he's blundering a little bit he's he's
stumbling in certain positions
nice e6 opening the center bononi style
now i'm going to try to activate my
knight frames i hope he doesn't take
if he takes i take with the knight he
has some stuff to deal with
what would be a good thing for black
here knight f4 would be a good move
so that you could basically take on your
own terms that's going to be something i
want to explain to him
another thing you could do is go
something like b5 chase the knight away
that would be another good move
and um yeah he's nervous but uh that
this is important because it's good
f5 good opening up the center
okay i'm going to take and i'm going to
try to get one of my knights to the d5
square
awesome thank you jack kelly well
appreciate you being part of the
community
e5 all right e5 ah e5 d6
oh my god i missed uh i missed an
amazing
positional breakthrough
okay so d5 is he really want this
oh my lens girl girl
queen g3 check really wow that's
actually very impressive
this is i'm quite impressed right now
the way he's playing i will never tell
that to him of course
i call myself a grandma and you call
yourself a moderator
oh my lance girl okay now i'm running
out of pieces he just wants to take on
knight f4
the best strategy in these positions
just trade off the remaining pieces so
you don't have anything to worry about
what was i worried about what was i
worried about
he just lost oh
what was i worried about
all right i'm gonna take let's see how
he reacts to this
yeah i'm down to play a little bit of
blitz after after with with somebody
after after my session
charlie
what was i worried about
all right rook to e8 would be a great
move here just bring the rook in
okay that was unnecessary there was no
need to bring the queen back
knight f4 would have also been good yes
knight f4 would have also been good yeah
so we're probably going gonna
we're gonna look at this game probably
he's gonna jump back into the pool for
one or two more games
and uh we'll call it a session i mean
this is awesome he's actually retained
a lot of his strength and i'm actually
very happy he said now again full
disclosure guys i don't know
who is in pogchamps three honest to god
it's not like i've been told and told
not to say it
i simply do not know i know mr beast is
playing that was leaked
that's all i know i don't know whether
charlie's been reinvited i really hope
so if charlie was invited to park champ
three
i will brook no trespass
to make sure he is in a position to win
uh to win the the whole thing i'm gonna
go c3 now two undefended pieces he can
attack both with queen e3
oh man
that's a good expression remember that
expert that's a good expression actually
it's an old school expression
you can look it up
it's a good expression dude we would
grind
i think charlie would have i really hope
he's invited i he if there's anyone who
deserves it
it's this guy i mean look at how he's
playing this is a guy who barely knew
the rules of chess before pogchamps won
and um he's he's just smoothly
converting this and people can take it
for granted but but this represents some
really
good work he's playing extremely well
knight of four's checkmate
he just needs to realize that he just
needs to activate that one last piece
queenie one what was i worried about
my throbbing throbbing
oh it's throbbing again i would you know
i wouldn't mind
helping fgc out either it's not like i'm
playing
competitor here but charlie will always
have a place in my heart of course
okay king h dude this is exactly what we
practiced for exactly what we practiced
for
yeah if i had a rook on a1 okay i would
i would also recommend taking the knight
here
uh that would have been a reasonable
alternative to that
shinobu 2s thank you for the sub yeah i
think uh charlie's going to win this now
i i think he has enough pieces yeah [ __ ]
yeah
what was i worried about what was i
worried about that was actually really
nice
um that was pretty smooth and
there were times i was predicting you
know what would the best move would be
and you made it
uh just i really only have one or two
points even to make
uh and i will make them so one sec
and did you ever thought you'd be
beating up a gm like this i know my
dreams you today i'm sorry about that
jesus that was
ruthless nothing to apologize for
all right i invited you to an house is
born
okay i feel like i had a much better
attacking opportunity after i made that
check with the knight and the queen but
i didn't see it in time and this was the
start of the game or the end
towards the end yeah i mean toward the
end there were several ways you could
attack in a slightly more efficient way
but i'll put it this way you didn't give
me any chances
so everything you did in the start was
good you
deployed your queen um the one thing
that
i hope you notice is that the bishop
x-rays the queen which means i can move
my knight out let's say to d5 and if i
were to do that where would you go with
your queen you actually have only one
good square
yeah with the only square is d8 right
yeah which is okay and
again i want you to remind you
retreating moves are totally acceptable
and uh i was more i was happy with your
capacity to make them just queen back
you know and now c5 is really good
opening the center i assume that was
your idea
and yeah i tried to keep the center
closed
and uh in the chat i have the honor of
having one of the
top players in the world uh and he
suggested
the move e5 that would have probably
complicated the position more
and um basically i want you to
understand the idea though e5
if d takes e5 what is white's next move
going to be
you just take with the knight right well
then queen takes knight oh
right okay wait wait uh this is a a
classic pawn breakthrough
is it just pushing that pat the d5 pawn
it's pushing the d5 pawn to d6 so i want
you to calculate in your head
pawn up to d6 what is that a combo what
does that threaten
it attacks my queen it attacks the queen
um
and one second it attacks the queen
queen moves away let's say to d8 what
does white do
what is going to be that look like
follow up to that move
oh after queen falls to d8 you have pawn
on d6 do you move knight up now um you
move the knight up and take e5
okay yeah so this is the idea and the
i'll show you right after the game
like in terms of understanding how you
find this stuff that's why
analyzing when you're like full scale
going for improvement
that's why reading books is really
important that's why looking at games is
important because you unders
you see these literal concepts applied
in games and then you can transfer them
to your own games but once i took
uh everything you did was d5 was
freaking sexy as hell
this was a really really nice idea
sacking the pawn getting the queen of g3
this basically ends the game but i want
you to tell me where you think you
missed that bigger chance
where did you play after i made this
move i don't remember i won king f1
okay um so when i when i made the move i
thought i had a much better idea i
thought i could also take
pawn but i obviously wouldn't get
anything out of it if i take your h4
pawn i mean i guess i take and then
slide to h1 maybe but
maybe our knight to g3 i mean there's so
many ways to do it here what i really
liked about what you did is you
developed the rest of your pieces that's
the principle that i want to hammer home
is never forget about the rest of your
pieces always bring
everything into the attack that makes it
a lot stronger and you did that
the one criticism i have in this
position
you don't actually need to bring your
queen back you can play rook a to e8
and what's the idea if i just take the
pawn of the knight
i'm just swinging down at e1 for the
checkmate bingo checkmate on e1
and that would have ended the game a
little bit faster but everything you did
was totally fine and rookie was good
here just not ignoring the knight
yeah perfect i mean you don't have to
stack the ropes you can go like rookie
two straight away
yeah i actually don't even know why i
stacked the rooks i think it was like
i don't know time pressure just wasn't
thinking just going to rub it in my face
and that's really what you were trying
to do
that's what it is but this was well done
so just really quickly um
as you were thinking i looked up on
on my program here whether i could find
examples of this precise breakthrough
happening and i found a couple of good
examples here's one of them so let's see
if this actually works the position
setup is notorious
but let's see if can you see the
position i
let me check your stream yeah it's a
different position awesome yeah you
actually see it so this is a game
between
wolfgang ph and gunther mooring
so white was a gm this was 1961
germany so that's the beauty you can
find these random games
and what do you think white does in this
position
white breaking through yeah so literally
apply the same concept
that you had in your game to this game
because
notice that black's king is uncastled
and white's king
is castle so if you can open up the
center you are able to exploit in a
better way the fact that black is not
castled
and if you need me to remind you what
your idea was
or what my idea was that i could have
done in the game
happy to do that is it pushing the pawn
up
which one uh so white's pushing up the
it's e5 right so e5 you're clearing the
path
and now and now you're pushing that pawn
again right to d6
exactly and you're ripping open the
center trying to keep black skin
that's literally what white did so
that's what this gm did and
let's say you were to read this in a
book you wouldn't have forgotten this
idea and you would be
more able to find this kind of stuff
that's how like pattern recognition
works
so this random game in like 1961 can
teach you about
uh can teach you about um you know
this concept and just one more quick
thing
just one second just because i have to
show you a game from the soviet union
because that's
to pay homage to my ancestors this is
another example
you see the new position yep you see the
bishop on c4
x-raying the king how do we make that
x-ray come alive
well we need to move the d5 pawn which
is blocked by the d6 pawn on black so
you're pushing exactly e4
exactly we need to get that pawn out
boom look at this monster and d6 black's
position collapses
and white won the game nice and uh
yeah that's white was a very strong
attacking player from the soviet union
again 1961.
so anyways um just wanted to inspire you
a little bit
so does this make sense does everything
make sense in the odds game yeah
yeah you played you played perfectly
actually so i'm pretty encouraged so
for the home stretch what do you say you
hop back in for one or two more games
and
then we'll summarize whenever you're
ready ah of course jmd ms z
okay this is tillian uh
damn what was the line that you told me
to play here is it pushing d4 next d4
correct
you want to open that's called the open
literally called the open situation
okay now you don't want to again this
you don't want to react to this
because if he takes your knight you can
simply take with a queen so you can just
develop normally
bingo now your bishops where do they
belong
isn't it f4 or yeah f4 for this bishop
even more oh you mean well you mean the
light squared bishop
the dark square bishop more active than
f4 f4 blunders a fork to e5
so you can put it on g5 uh i see
yeah okay so yeah if you put it on f4 he
he goes e5
there oh okay
that's kind of wacky um
i don't know how to exploit that though
so like think about his knight on f6
he's actually weakened his control over
that knight if you take the knight on m6
notice that he has to ruin his entire
pawn structure by taking it with that
pawn
so i would do that you think that's
worth okay it is worth it because his
pawn structure is going to be terrible
now
i would immediately prepare queen side
castle because you were going to attack
him on the king side
and you want to tuck your king away on
the queen side okay and
what is the most active development for
queen is it going over here to like
f3 well your queen's defending the
knight so you want to keep it on the
d-file
right and i would put it on t2 i would
prevent black's bishop from coming out
to h6 and stopping you from castling
so and if he plays bishop g7 and
fianchettos
look at that pawn on d6 you see that
it's weak right
it's undefended by any other pawns
um sorry you heard me there right
yeah yeah okay okay so now uh he's
attacking your knight
how can you defend it
where can you put it yeah i just need to
move it there's nothing else i can
defend it with do i just drop it back to
like either well what's better
well b3 would be good because that stops
them from taking the pawn on b2
okay yeah just a low-key move but it's a
good one thanks beast best beetle for
gifting
and look at his queen on v6 you can
attack that queen in the future by
playing
okay actually complete the development
first
so now i'm castling queen side and then
to attack the queen is it bringing the
knight over to a4
so that brings the knight to the rim can
you send can you actually okay so first
he takes this
do i take back with the c pawn or does
it not really matter here doesn't c pawn
is good
keeping that a pawn where it closes up
the a file
whoa holy smokes oh my god
jesus wow that came out of nowhere
oh my god
that literally caused a physical
reaction
i could hear you [ __ ] fall out of
your chair there for a second i thought
i'd lost you i rolled back from my desk
the confidence with which this move was
it was like
with gusto okay
but let's not relax you you have some
developing to do
deplete your development is it just b5
here for the chat yeah i'm like that
mother that tells
you know the child to finish their
oatmeal even though you just won the
lottery or something
yeah she still trying to finish that
oatmeal
this could be his like legendary line
this is
this could be the one the history books
remember him for the secondary track sir
so now you have a fork actually let's
practice
that thing i tortured you with
previously what are the undefended
pieces and pawns how can you attack
two of them okay so right now undefended
pawns
are d6 it's defended by bishop but no
pawns
f6 f6 is completely undefended and the
knight is completely undefeated
it's ready to go forks forks forks
well his legendary i think really the
mistake that he made wasn't to take the
okay wool but careful there's a trap
that's hiding under the surface
now you can take the pawn yeah but if he
moves his king out you actually
can't take the rook and that is the
bottom line of that's an entire point of
his variation i think
let's see what if he covers with the
bishop that would be very sad
i think he just might though i think he
might unfortunately cover with his
bishop
or resign this guy's got some goofy
strats i wouldn't put it by him
so um well i guess i'll wait
i moved to this game so you can't take
the rook why
uh let me see if i take rook x right
oh yeah he's just gonna move bishop
right yeah
check on h6 so you can do the next best
thing
take the stuff that you can take yeah do
i just want to take this pawn then
yeah absolutely he's probably gonna go
king to b6
and then you have kind of a sexy move
all right guys what
is my chat doing what are you guys
drawing
all right guys all right guys
all right guys we're not gonna go sub
only please stop
we're not gonna go sub only but please
stop uh
we're having fun guys guys we're having
fun but but let's let's stop please
one one last request please stop that
it's annoying
or we're gonna go sub only if people
can't
guys i'm i don't ask a lot of you but
when i ask you to stop
please do okay so oh shoot
okay so you have a sexy move here
you can deliver a check to a4 with the
knight
and i want you to do that but i want you
to tell me why we're not blundering the
bishop once you do it you can play the
move because you've got a minute
okay
he might think you blundered your bishop
that's what i'm hoping yes he did
okay checkmate find it it's just c4 red
oh that's even sexier than the maid i
had in mind i was thinking
take the pawn with mate but that's even
cooler because you dropped the piece
back
yes nice cool thank you for listening
guys exactly
which one would which one did you say
queen takes b7 check me
uh okay i see yeah well this is the one
i saw right away i thought this was kind
of cute
no that's really nice i mean because the
knight from the rim is defending b6
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
yeah i mean queen takes b3 made it a
little bit easier for you
but everything was pretty
straightforward what do you say we do
one last one for the road
i'm ready so that queen play he made was
that an accident or did he actually get
anything out of that
no zero i mean he gives up literally a
queen for the for a pawn
i think he i think it might have been a
mouse left like one of those things
where you accidentally like pre-move
something
but um no other than that i mean i
i honestly have no idea what went
through his mind i wonder what went
through that guy's mind but
we'll never find out okay e3 interesting
the van crew is opening
okay maybe he'll play e4 and transpose
to being black
oh this is a this is a real thinker it
seems yeah yeah
santa claus i think he's busy delivering
presents to people
okay nice
defending the pawn this is like a
reverse french basically
in a position like this a lot of times
what i do is just push e4 is that a good
move or not
it is you close up the center that's a
different type of position and the next
one of the next steps to improvement is
to be able to play
skillfully these types of positions now
what no just yes knight f6 is fine
defending
and if you want to defend the pawn
further he'll probably go knight c3
which would not be his oh his
well that is not very active you want to
make sure that pawn on e4 is as well
protected as possible so in with that in
mind what do you want to do
i want to go d5 bingo and for the record
his best move would be to undermine this
pawn chain by bringing his pawn okay he
does that wow
that's impressive after going c3 so now
what you want to do that pawn on e4
you see that it's going to become weak
after he takes d5
yeah so basically you want to
preemptively defend it as many times as
possible so that
you don't lose that pawn once he takes
on d5
how do you do that i just developed the
bishop over to f5
yes
yeah close positions can be annoying but
the yeah okay so he takes what do you
take with
yeah i was going to ask uh developing
queen here and going castle long is that
a good idea
that's interesting but if you take with
the queen he'll develop his knight to c3
and he'll attack your queen
so that's really honestly the litmus
test for when you take with the queen
can he
attack your queen with one of his pieces
he does it anyway
so do you want to take
um no doesn't it make his pawn chain
stronger if i take because he
does on the other hand he's attacking
your pawn on e4
so this would be a good time for a
retreating move
which one i just bring it back to its
original fs exactly
exactly defending the pawn
okay now here's the thing
he is kind of threatening to take the
pawn but i would sacrifice that pawn i'd
do something pretty cool here i would
just develop
normally which means that bishop from f8
what would be a nice active defended
square for it
just bringing it up to d6 yeah and
here's the thing he'll probably take the
pawn in about five seconds yep
yep now you want to take once and what
you'll notice here is that there's a pin
right what do you want to take on e4
with i would i want to take with bishop
to attack queen yeah
no but then he'll take the bishop you
want to take with the knight to preserve
the building oh i see
and now you can deliver a check to an
exposed flank
and you'll see what the result is what
check am i talking about here
you're talking about b4 bingo here's the
problem he's probably going
to very quickly cover that with a bishop
he said he was a thinker i think you
jinxed him now he's playing
go ahead okay he'll probably go bishop
to d2
would be my guess and then once you take
it can he take back with the queen
no because then he gives up the knight
bingo that's the that's the power of men
he has to move his king out into the
center
that's a pretty disastrous consequence
that's worth the freaking pawn so go
ahead
okay you see what but you see the logic
of what i'm saying
yeah i get it now you need to complete
your development though
just castle and king's side and the plan
is
his best move is well oh that's a good
move actually but you can actually
get that bishop off the board with one
move oh
can't i fork them at b4 yeah so
technically it's not a fork because
you're not gonna win the bishop but
you're gonna take it and re
restore the pin yeah attacking two
pieces
yep
um well you got your prize take the
bishop
can he just take back with the king oh
it still keeps yeah when he does
but you're not winning anything you're
just restoring the pin now you want to
open up the center
because a pin is most exploitable if you
can rip apart the center
okay uh to do that are we looking at c5
here
yes exactly
exactly and if he takes that okay yeah
he's actually started his play really
really well
but you can open up the center
i'm still taking that didn't change open
that now if he takes of the pawn which
you probably will
you want to find a way to attack that d4
pawn to attack it you need to get a rook
to d8
and you need to move the queen to a
square where it pressures the pawn which
square am i talking about
d5 uh or b6 because then
that lead leaves the rook to attack the
pawn alone
if that makes it okay so b6 is or wait
yeah
queen b6 is good because also you're
attacking the b2 pawn
i see okay yeah this guy has all of us
okay
so what now now you can just take the
free pawn on b2
is that better do i want to set up for
this d8 pin well if you go to d
it'll move his king back i think that's
the idea of his last move so you need to
change your plans a little bit take some
pawns
i'll get you okay now what
there's another three oh wait no i can
just swing over here for this
other pawn exactly
he's probably gonna go rook to d2 i
think i know the type of player he is
let's see he's gonna put something on
the second rank
i'm hoping it's his queen and then i
that would be kind of good though
yeah that'd be very nice okay first rank
he blunders another pawn
yeah so now i'm still just taking this
h2 mm-hmm
okay now your two pawns off now the
knight on e4 is what you need to be
paying attention to
that knight is okay he moves it and he
actually you've got checkmate
you don't even need to take his knight
look at his king his king is confined
which means if you give him a check it's
going to be mate what do you do
is it just going to g3 nope queen is
guarding the king what other checkmate
he's opened up the e file
um put a rook there
oh and then he takes it i take back yes
and it's checkmate
yeah so pre-move rook takes e8 he's
probably going to think you blunted the
rook
if he brings his knight back to e4 which
would be the correct move you can take
the knight
with the bishop and now it's going to be
checkmate
yeah go ahead and deliver the mate oh
whoops
correct correct now but take your time
after queenie two
which way do you take the queen what's
that which way do you take the queen
what do you mean okay what is the mate
here
it's just taking the queen mcqueen with
oh yeah just making sure you know that
you know okay you scared me for a second
yeah six seconds like oh my god
so that guy was weird he played well for
certain stretches sorry what were you
saying
i just panicked there at the end there
for a second i thought i had less time
all right your balls like frost oh my
god
so that guy was weird he played well for
certain stretches sorry what were you
saying
i just panicked there at the end there
for a second i thought i had less time
all right your balls like frost oh my
god
so okay let's very quickly talk about it
then maybe make a couple summarizing
points
and uh what do you say to that sounds
good
all right let me invite you wow you're
really winning these games with
seconds on the clock photo finishes
so basically okay
it's your beaufisto
yeah invited
did you get the invite i toss it one
more time sure
i was like you're not even i'm gonna
reply to me when
you're i'm i'm inviting you to something
i'm an [ __ ] are you
well i've already beaten you once today
i don't i don't respect you anymore i
see it's got into your head
that's exactly what i feared so
basically here this move makes sense
right
attacking the base of the pawn chain
when there's a pawn chain you want to
attack the base
like removing the la the jenga block
from the from the bottom right so
everything collapses
so you're you're over protecting the e4
pawn
bringing the knight back at this whole
and now you're sacrificing it this is
the key
concept because of the pin his queen is
immobilized which means his queen can't
move away from this diagonal
and he's under understaffed in the other
parts of the board if that makes sense
so you make his king move
because he can't take with a queen he
would blunder his knight so i had a
question for that position before you
moved the bishop
couldn't would it have been viable to
just attack the queen
on b4 to try and relinquish the control
it has over e4
that that's a good move conceptually but
it's a blunder tactically because he can
take on d6 with check
uh okay and then what can he do
and then he just takes bishop yeah
exactly so if you were castled for
example that would be a perfectly good
move
uh so castling here would also be
possible to set that up but he would
probably stop it
so now you castle and knight before
right i wanted to make clear that you're
not actually winning any pieces here
immediately
but the bishop on d3 is an annoying
piece because it it blocks the pin
and it lets this queen have mobility
right does that make sense yeah and now
opening the center so if he had taken on
c5
how specifically do you win the piece
here i just take the knight with bishop
exactly and because of the other pin you
can you just win a piece
yeah so he goes f3 which is a really
good move he's protecting the knight
now queen b6 why not queen d5 this is
the concept of like the queen as the
supporting actress
if you play queen d5 look what happens
you go rook let's say white make
something random
and now you're like great you take the
pawn and white just says
big [ __ ] you trade queens okay and
you've won only upon
now let's compare this to if you put the
queen on v6 as you did
now what do you take the pawn with the
rook
exactly and you pin the queen so you see
the queen is supporting the rook and the
rook is doing the actual
capturing because of the logic that
winning the queen is best done with as
weak of a resource as possible does that
make sense yeah that makes sense so when
you're thinking of piling the what is
the
conclude specific rule here when you're
piling up on a pawn
uh you usually don't want the queen to
lead that operation you want the queen
to be the general from behind
normally and also
you have this one thing which is that
and this is the form of tunnel vision
where you wanted to go here
do you see what white would have done
had you done that
look what was the idea of this move this
was actually kind of a
sensible idea he was just going to move
his king out of the way
yes and that makes helps make things
safer and
the fact of the matter is this is not
the important part anymore now you want
to take here
what if he had blocked with his queen
what would you have done
uh i could have delivered a check at b4
and then well that's not
close but he's relinquished his control
over something
yeah he's got the knight just hanging
now no that knight is defended
oh jesus oh man um very close to getting
something chopped off right now
yeah yeah just just as you were left on
a high note
and just left the pod open the pawn open
yeah so again
it's always about making a map of the
board what is weak what do i need to
watch for
and you need to watch those things
constantly okay has he relinquished his
control over that
right and here the pawn would be high on
your list so now take stakes
and here the key concept you what can
you do here what's the obvious move that
wins
a lot of material taking the knight
taking the knight but
rookie check the point is the queen is
cutting off the king kind of like the
checkmate we learned
at the start of our you know well shin
dig
um remember we learned that the two
rooks made that like time in the 1970s
you remember that
yeah it's back when we were young and
you know we were still going on runs and
stuff
and now we're just old men sitting
around computers these old veterans
those were the days you know i hung out
with carol traxler i mean
that's good a good a good man yeah at
least it's not
you know because carol is a name and
then karen
is an armenian name so i have a friend
whose name is
karen it's pronounced karen but people
look at it and they're like what
karen gregorian like hi karen but it's
actually a male name in
armenia so same with carol
i guess carol is also a female name in
the us
but anyways rookie eight you deliver the
queen holds the king down
and if he takes on e8 then what do you
do thanks
thanks for the gift to the tier two to
many can't appreciate it this is this is
just checkmate
94 bishop takes c4 last question to you
you better end in a haina or i'll chop
those nuts up right before you escape
if he goes queenie two what is the best
move for black
and what i'm really asking you here is
is it a good idea to take the queen is
there anything better
um i
[Music]
i don't see why you wouldn't just go h1
isn't that
not h1 g1 isn't that just checkmate uh
king can escape oh i give us oh you get
the square
so what you need to watch for is this
right
what does your brand need to signal to
ah the queen and the king are on the
same
file which means what and you have many
good moves here it's
it's x-rayed so if i just get the bishop
out of the way she can exactly anywhere
really but you can also just like while
you're at it you can just take on f3
right but even like bishop freaking b1
is good
it's it's about the theme exploiting the
theme here of the queen being x-rayed
and pinned yeah
and one exactly and by the way if rook
d2
this should be one rook d2 find the
checkmate in one move
now it's your move well yeah now that
the square's cut off now it is just g2
exactly and here he takes you take let's
check me
very good so things to watch for
conclusions you're still
very sharp at like one move tactics and
stuff you're not blending pieces
um and and how does it feel like do you
feel relatively
in the zone sharp is there anything that
you kind of struggle with so i can
factor that in for next time time again
yeah yeah priorities i i don't really
know when
i should be taking pawns or looking for
something better like when the pawns are
free i'll typically look for something
better still
yeah i noticed that even with pieces
sometimes there's a free piece but
you're looking at like winning the queen
and that's something that you know will
definitely break down
is when do you take upon when you look
for something more and also
i know you're dreading but we'll
eventually have to do that exercise with
uh
me giving you like one minute and having
you win positions with
like down acquainted tours i actually
think that helped you've gotten like
noticeably faster
and i'm not gonna pretend that that's a
spill over all from that but i think
that definitely contributed so
by and large i'm happy with where you
are i think you've got the basics down
and uh i'm just uh you know again i'm
really grateful that
you made time for this um i know it's
not easy to get abused by me
but uh it's always welcome that it's
good abuse i would say
some of the best i've ever experienced
you're just making me blush now
the gentle fist they call you well they
call
and they call you the turbo fist well
all right sure i think that was
a good good amount of time i think i
packed you with enough information
tortured you enough
i'll let you um do
overdoses on ketamine and other such
stuff
[Music]
you